depuis quelques semaines notre pays fait
face à la propagation d'un virus
[Musique]
salut je m'appelle famille handicapée
régulièrement sur cette chaîne je fais
des analyses de vidéos qui ont fait
l'actualité ou deux plus anciennes
vidéos dire que j'ai reçu des milliers
de commentaires et de messages sur les
réseaux sociaux depuis jeudi pour faire
une analyse du discours d' emmanuel
macron saurait 1,12 féminisme
alors on va analyser cette vidéo cette
analyse va mélanger ce qu'on peut
trouver en non verbale mais aussi
exceptionnellement ce qu'on veut trouver
en verbal pour essayer d'avoir une
complexité un peu plus grande parce que
commencer souvenez vous de lancer une
vidéo sur les gilet jaune qui contrôlent
beaucoup sont non verbale il nous faut
de la matière supplémentaire donc c'est
parti pour ceux qui ont l'habitude de
regarder mes analyses vous pouvez allez
une petite minute en avant pour ceux qui
regardent la chaîne pour la première
fois il ya une minute pour vous a écouté
c'est important si vous regardez mes
vidéos pour la première fois sachez que
ce genre de l'analyse va utiliser des
outils que j'ai pioché dans tout le
monde entier des possibles mais ça reste
mon avis à moi se taire que je vais
utiliser aussi des trucs de psychologie
mais aussi les trucs de pseudo science
comme la pnl comme la synergologie qui
sont plus qu'à prendre avec des
pincettes
ne croyez pas ce que je dis comme étant
la vérité c'est mon avis à moi je fais
une analyse une hypothèse on va dire
mais ce n'est pas scientifique ce n'est
pas la vérité
et si un jour vous faites une vidéo sur
moi comme ça arrive souvent arrêtés
d'enlever ce disque les moeurs à ses
rôles ou et les deux dernières choses
pourquoi vous verrez la vidéo sur mon
écran c'est pour éviter le strike pour
droits d'auteur sur youtube et enfin
puisque c'est la première fois que vous
regardez l'une de mes vidéos et bien
bonne et vous c'est gratuit
et moi ça m'aide donc je voulais ceci
vous abonner allez c'est parti patriote
depuis quelques semaines notre pays fait
face à la propagation d'un virus
le coc vide 19 qui a touché plusieurs
milliers de nos compatriotes
j'ai bien entendu ce soir avant toute
chose une pensée émue et chaleureuse
pour les familles et les produits novik
la première chose qu'on peut dire je la
trouve assez intéressante je n'ai pas
encore regardé sur internet s'il ya des
choses qui sont 10 par rapport à ça ou
pas mais peu importe je pense que mon
analyse peut être viable à ce moment là
on sait de manière sûre et certaine
qu'ils parlent avec un prompteur
pourquoi on le sait parce que le regard
est toujours centre est vraiment people
au centre de la caméra il n'y a pas de
décrochage alors que quand on récite un
discours il ya des décroche troubles
potentiels et il a pris des petites
respirations exactement comme il ya là
qui sont pas des respirations normale
dans le texte
en fait il a un temps la suite du texte
ou qu'on rétablisse
qu'on accélère au conte remettre ça se
passe comme ça qu'on utilise un
prompteur
du coup puisqu'il utilise un prompteur
ça veut dire que le discours et écrits
j'essaie plutôt normal et est important
de le faire sur une déclaration comme
celle ci sauf que comme le discours
écrit on pourrait se demander pourquoi
sa galère temps à marquer les sous
titres en bas pourquoi ils ont pas juste
le plateau de le texte initial et
pourquoi ils ne mettent pas au fur et à
mesure qu'ils étaient posés la question
lui coupa tu vois bon pourquoi ne pas
l'avoir mis directement
je pense que comme on a une notion de
direct parce que ça a été enregistrée et
diffusée en direct le fait d'avoir
quelqu'un qui écrit le texte fur et à
mesure et donc comme ça arrive toujours
dense et une situation qui rectifie qui
revient en arrière qui remet ça donne un
sentiment de proximité et d'immédiateté
c'est à dire que on se dit pas forcément
justement que le texte est préparé à
l'avancé et qui un prompteur
on a l'impression d' à la sensation qui
nous parle là réellement autant x et
qu'il invente son discours au fur et à
mesure et donc qui connaît par coeur les
données qui va nous donner qui est qu'il
invente son fils de penser au fur et à
mesure ça donne une forme de puissance
et de confiance de faire ça mais là pour
le coup c'est pas le cas
le discours était pré écrit et on voit
qu'il est sur un prompteur en quoi on
pourrait se dire oui mais s'ils avaient
décidé de changer un truc et tout mais
non il va rien changer il n'a pas un
loïc comme toi derrière la caméra qui va
dire à quelle date on est aujourd'hui
dans ce bas possible la deuxième chose
qu'on peut se dire par rapport à la
première vidéo où j'avais fait sur les
gilet jaune que vous aurez peut-être
dans la description sauf si tu oublies
c'est ce qui arrive à peu près
régulièrement c'est que là ils ont cadré
pour pas qu'on puisse voir ses mains ça
veut dire qu'il n'a pas besoin de se
retenir comme il l'avait fait dans la
première vidéo parce que tu m'as bien on
voit pas le bas ce qui explique tous ces
gestes parasites les mains qui commence
à bouger etc
on voit qu'il a moins à faire attention
et qui comme ça il a juste à se
concentrer sur son visage qui sont âgés
ou affectés par des maladies chroniques
comme le diabète l'obésité ou le camp ce
les personnels des hôpitaux médecins
infirmer on a énormément de mouvements
de sourcil qu'ils soient ensemble ou
comme l'a complètement dissociés alors
on pourrait être tenté d interpréter
mais là il faut pas du tout c'est pour
le coup c'est ce qu'on appelle des
mouvements d'interprétation
et d'interprètes tout court dire que là
il a interprète du texte ce moment là il
n'est pas intérieurement dans la
réflexion liée à ces textes là il essaye
de bien récitée comme on réussit très
bien une histoire un conte ou une blague
bon ben là c'est pas très drôle comme
blague et du coup on va on va y mettre
des intentions de jeu dans la voix mais
aussi dans le visage
c'est à dire que si je vous dis il était
une fois dans un endroit
oui je vais bouger mes sorties pour pour
donner de la matière et pour donner de
l'épaisseur à ce que je raconte mais ça
veut pas dire que j'ai une réflexion
interne sur ce que je dis qu'il va
transparaître et de là en l'occurrence
on le voit c'est pas le cas d'où les
sourcils dissocier des fouilles star par
contre juste avant il s'est passé un
tout petit truc là regardez l'ensemble
des personnels du service public de la
santé en france sont engagés avec
dévouement et efficacité
si nous avons pu retarder la propagande
qui se passe à chaque fois qu'ils
parlent de nous donc nous le
gouvernement l'état français y baissent
l'intonation de la voix
ça c'est du non verbal intonations la
prosodie fait parti du non verbal
ils baissent intonations de la voix il
rapproche un petit peu son corps de la
caméra c'est très léger mais maintenant
vous le savez regarder on va le voir
l'ag avec dévouement et efficacité
là il revient à nous si nous avons pu la
retarde vous avez vu vraiment la
différence entre quand il parlait des
autres et nous et avec la voix qui se
baissent un peu qui devient un peu plus
grave c'est quelque chose pour
transmettre de la sûreté de la sécurité
de la proximité
on voit que ça il al'habitude de cet
exercice ou que ça a été réfléchi en
amont mais en tout cas il ya une vraie
volonté à ce moment-là de d'essayer de
se confier et non pas de se positionner
en force ont accepté de prendre du temps
sur leur vie personnelle familiale pour
notre santé et le décalage de pour notre
santé n'est pas du tout logique
ça aussi c'est un élément qui tend à
dire qu'il un prompteur qui n'ont
d'autre boussole que le soin d'autres
préoccupations que l'humain notre
bien-être notre vie tout simplement sais
pas comment analyser celle ci donc il ya
juste dire notre vie tout simplement
il lâche pas l'écran des yeux parce
qu'il ya le procter ces taxis on avait
un doute jusque là on a plus aucun doute
en maintenant sa qui pourrait passer
comme de l'arrogance n'est pas parce que
la tête est légèrement penchée
puis les yeux ne correspondent pas mon à
la bouche fermée
je pense juste peut-être qu'il ya un
retard de textes à l'écran et que celle
soul un peu et que comme il avait mal
géré sa respiration il va devoir
déglutir voilà juste là le texte va
reprendre
il va repasser en expression de neutre
pour essayer de rien laissé
transparaître et reprend je vous sens
qu'elle soir en fait on a juste une
décroche personnel avant qu'ils rentrent
dans son rôle d'interprète en ne cédant
ni à la colère ni à la panique
mieux en adoptant les bons gestes vous
avait ralenti la diffusion du virus et
ainsi permis à nos hôpitaux et nos
soignants de mieux se préparer
alors ça c'est une vieille technique de
manipulation là je vais parler du verbal
pour le coup le fait de nous féliciter
pour quelque chose à outrance en donnant
tous les détails de cette chose qu'on a
potentiellement fait ça nous aide à
rentrer dans le rang et en fait à ne pas
décevoir
imaginez vous avez un groupe d'enfants
avec vous et puis dans le tie un petit
garçon un petit peu turbulent et vous
arrivez pas trop à le gérer et à le
faire rentrer dans les règles établies
vous allez le responsabiliser en étant
bastien tu sais quoi peser sur le trajet
c'est toi qui va tenir le ballon parce
que je te félicite comme à chaque fois
tu es responsable comme je donne les
consignes j'ai confiance en toi et je
sais que toi tu vas bien amener le
ballon sans qu'ils aillent sur la route
par exemple eh bien en fait vous créez
une valeur ce moment-là ce petit garçon
là et même s'il n'a pas fait ce que vous
avez dit avant il a envie maintenant
d'être vraiment dans ce que vous avez
dit est d'être la personne que vous
venez de décrire
donc ça c'est un moyen de nous impliquer
tous merci important de s'impliquer sur
la limitation du corps d'un virus est là
et bien c'est fait de manière un petit
peu détournée en utilisant une technique
et psychologique
cependant mes chers compatriotes j'ai un
petit pincement élèves mais je crois
qu'il est forcée alors voilà ça c'est
pareil on pourrait dire là il se passe
quelque chose ça c'est pas un micro
expressions c'est une expression c'est à
dire c'est décidé consciemment d'avoir
cette tête là elle arrive trop lentement
et elle repart trop lentement une micro
expressions est beaucoup plus rapide que
ça
donc là on auront lieu sur une
expression traditionnelle et puis c'est
un petit peu comme un truc dont je vous
avais parlé sur la chaîne qui s'appelle
le sourire de duchenne si on cache le
bas du visage on voit que le regard
n'exprime pas forcément ce qu'on essaye
de nous donner
ici par le bas du visage faut pas se
faire avoir aussi par ça en voulant
analyser un petit peu de quoi voir de
croire voir des signes partout alors que
ce sont des signes qui sont voulus à ce
moment là et partout en europe
elle s'accélère elle s'intensifie face à
cela la priorité absolue pour notre
nation il ya une démonstration de
puissance il nous parlait il était très
rapproché quand il va dire face à cela
il va parler au nom de l'état et au nom
de lui vous allez voir un redressement
pour renvoyer de la puissance est
partout en europe
très rapproché les accélère elle
s'intensifie de baisse et à plat face à
savoir la crise puis pour la gérer
depuis plusieurs semaines et il doit
continuer de le faire je sais pas du
tout quoi ça correspond
ces petits chassé croisé là il doit
continuer de le faire vite et c'est ça
il doit continuer de le faire
est-ce qu'il ya quelque chose qu'il gêne
dans le champ de vision et qu'il a voulu
voir quelque chose peut-être quelqu'un
qui a bougé derrière nous avons en
france les meilleurs virologues les
meilleurs épidémiologistes
alors ça te raconte ça me fatigue on va
passer sur le verbal le mensonge passe
en général par les superlatifs
vraiment je te jure que je t'assure que
là on dit la vérité on n'a pas besoin de
dire ça mais là il vient de dire on a
les meilleurs virologues les meilleures
personnes le meilleur trump a affirmé
qu'ils avaient les meilleurs médecins et
les meilleurs scientifiques et les
meilleurs cerveaux l'australie a affirmé
avoir les meilleures personnes les
meilleurs médecins les meilleurs
scientifiques les meilleurs cerveaux le
meilleur ce que vous voulez le canada a
affirmé avoir les meilleurs docteurs
nous on avait en fait on a tous les
meilleurs ça c'est vraiment un truc dont
on pourrait se passer en fait on a
d'excellents médecins par exemple chaque
chaque pays et chaque chef d'état
devrait dire ça et surtout nous
communiquons entre tous les pays
pourrait pour réunir les meilleurs
spécialistes de chaque domaine pouvant
nous aider à intervenir
c'est vraiment là le discours là c'est
de l'analyse verbales mais c'est
vraiment le discours qu'ils pourraient
avoir à ce moment là là c'est une figure
de style c'est un effet de manche qui
n'a pas du tout son utilité dans un
discours des gens qui sont sur le
terrain et que nous avons écouté comme
nous faisons depuis le premier jour tu
es un doute c'est ce que tu aimes venir
mettant là c'est le génial par contre
les hésitations elle est pas joué du
tout regardez bien
que nous avons écouté et en fait ce qui
veut dire c'est toutes ces personnes là
que nous avons écouté depuis le premier
jour de grand renom des cliniciens aussi
des gens qui sont sur le terrain et que
nous avons et que nous avons regardé au
mot là il se passe un truc donc
peut-être que l'écran un bug ou parce
que là on voit vraiment le début de la
peur a les yeux qui s'écarquillent up
les sursis qui se lève un petit peu on a
les premières ridules du front la bouche
légèrement entrouverte
ça c'est le début d'un signe de peur
donc je pense qu'un tout petit bug à
l'écran ou autre chose qui se passe
derrière on n'a pas la baseline on sait
pas ce que lui voit mais il se passe
quelque chose qui l'inquiète c'est pas
de la vraie peur mais ça va de la quiète
et du coup il sait ce qu'il doit dire
que nous écoutons depuis le premier jour
et ça il va devoir le dire sincèrement
parle disant écoutez comme nous faisons
depuis le premier jour de depuis le
premier jour qui était pourtant réécrire
l'écran à ce moment là on le voit par
rapport à son regard l'a fait et c'était
bon il sait que non on ne sait pas de
quoi quand comment pourquoi mais tout
n'a pas été aussi facile que ça c'est la
première fois qu'il sort de sa zone de
confort c'est à dire il a la tête
légèrement penchée sur sa gauche depuis
le départ
là il va aller chercher complètement à
droite il va se repositionner c'est
vraiment de la déstabilisation physique
on la voit à ce moment là on l'entend
dans les intonations de la voix je vous
rappelle que les intonations s'est aussi
dit non verbale et on entend le trémolo
dans la voix pousser c'est terrible je
remets un coût pour le plaisir
écoutez comme nous faisons depuis le
premier jour tous nous ont dit que
malgré le contrôle à freiner ce sont là
nos priorités oh c'est pour cela qu'il
nous faut continuer de gagner du temps
et suivre celles et ceux qui sont les
plus fragiles
même le ciel la perturber il vient de
faire un truc qu'on appelle le schéma
c'est à dire que on sait qu'un schéma de
dessiner un schéma ça aide à la
compréhension ça aide à convaincre les
gens il ya des commerciaux en force de
vente ils font toujours un petit schéma
pour aider à convaincre parce que ça pas
et scientifique et surtout le cerveau m
absorbé des images il les comprend mieux
ce sont là nos priorités c'est pour cela
qu'il nous faut la continuer de gagner
du temps et là et suivre et en fait
cette gestuelle la halle été pensé
réfléchi on le voit au moment où il va
faire ça que pas du tout d'ailleurs un
geste naturel
on fait un discours clac clac donc en
fait tu renvoies l'inconscient de tout
va bien on se calme il faut aller de
l'avant et mettre quelque chose de côté
ou faire ce que je vous dis ourlets
s'est laissé sa peur de côté mon peu
importe ce qui veut dire derrière j'ai
pas écouté des mollahs pour le pour le
coup bon c'est pas la macarena non plus
mais on est sur quelque chose qui a été
pensé et c'est tellement perturbant à
faire dans un discours un moment précis
une gestuelle non naturel que tu as
pensé en amont que vous allez voir qu'à
la fin de la chorégraphie même lui
perturbé un tout petit peu et après il
reprend très vite le contrôle parce
qu'il est très fort note et suivre la
celle et ceux qui sont les plus fragiles
vous avez vu là il avait plus de
puissance dans la voix il savait plus
comment se repositionner et voilà lui
c'est la juste perturbée je me demande
vraiment s'il n'a pas des conseillers
des mecs comme moi qui le conseil en
amont de ce qui doit faire par rapport à
tout ça ça ça me perturbe toujours assez
que c'est ok je comprends mais aussi
j'injecte le verbal en fait c'est que là
c'est la première mesure c'est la
première annonce est la première demande
qui nous fait donc encore une fois qu'il
a utilisé le sens des mots le non verbal
le rapprochement la position de force il
fallait illustrer après une dernière
fois pour ensuite faire c'est pourquoi
je demande
il considère que rien ne s'oppose à ce
que les français même les plus
vulnérables se rendent aux urnes le se
rendent aux urnes
pareil dans la puissance vocale un papa
dans le sens des mots étaient beaucoup
plus timide et discret il considère que
rien ne s'oppose à ce que les français
même les plus vulnérables se rendre aux
urnes moi on est on est à deux fois plus
bas avec une vraie hésitation je pense
qu'à ce moment là mon interprétation et
celle ci c'est que lui même sait que
c'est compliqué de dire ça et je pense
vraiment d'ailleurs qu'il aurait dû
s'abstenir parce que ce doute la
renforce l'incompréhension qu'on a du
fait que tu demandes à toutes ces
personnes là ne pas sortir de chez elle
mais par contre elles peuvent aller
voter
on entend tout le doute dans sa voix
parce que lui même à ce moment là c'est
que c'est pas un bon discours c'est pas
un bon propos à tenir
voilà la priorité des priorités
aujourd'hui est donc
protéger les plus faibles celles et ceux
que cette épidémie touche d'abord petite
conclusion fallacieuse fallacieuse parce
que après avoir expliqué tout le système
des élections
il termine pas voilà donc notre priorité
le donc est très important à ce moment
là et donc de protéger les plus faibles
ça ne va pas c'était pas la conclusion
de ce qui venait d'être dit la
conclusion c'était la priorité est de
maintenir le système électoral en place
selon le calendrier établi
le gouvernement annoncera par ailleurs
des mesures pour limiter au maximum les
rassemblements là vous avez vu son
intonation était précis ils savent
exactement de quoi il parlait là on le
voit il connaît ce qu'il ya derrière
cette phrase en disant que le
gouvernement prendra des mesures pour
limiter au maximum les rassemblements il
s'est déjà à ce moment là qui va y avoir
d'ici quelques jours une interdiction
des rassemblements de plus de 100
personnes qui va être annoncé
pourquoi ils l'annoncent pas là à ce
moment là je suis pas politicien je peux
pas le dire à votre place je pense que
c'est pour qu'ils aient pas trop
d'annoncés d'un coup je pense que ça
aurait été compliqué peut-être
d'annoncer aux français d'un coup de les
écoles sont fermées les créations se
fermer les universités les lycées des
collèges et les rassemblements sont
interdits
ça faisait un peu trop d'un coup je
pense qu'ils sont dit on va diluer ça
mais ça vaut vraiment c'est mon avis à
moi quoi tu vois par contre voilà on
sait que lui il savait à ce moment là
que ce serait le cas je fais une mini
parenthèse de quelques secondes je suis
bien sûr impactés par ce à tous les
spectacles sont en suspens pour
l'instant jusqu'à début avril on pense
parce qu'on n'a pas encore la date
jeune annulerait aucun spectacle seront
tous reporter dans le temps
je vous tiens au courant de ça sur mes
réseaux sociaux comme instagram ou dents
longues les communautés de cette page
youtube et les billets que vous aviez
pour les spectacles là seront valables
pour les autres dates ou alors ils
seront remboursables si vous pouvez pas
venir mais pour répondre à la question
que vous m'envoyez tout sur les réseaux
ça concerne toutes les dates j'ai pas
j'ai pas une petite date comme ça dans
un coin qui est caché qui peut
accueillir toutes les manifestations
publiques que je devais faire
elles sont aux remises en cause et en
suspens pour le moment jusqu'à nouvel
art de joux tient au courant de tout ça
et beaucoup des décisions que nous
sommes en train alors ça c'est très
intéressant c'est la couverture des
mains quand les coups de sang sur la
table et que les mains se couvrent l'une
l'autre
comme ça on
on dit que ça témoigne du mode de
raisonnement de la personne qui est en
face de nous alors attention ça c'est de
la synergologie et je le dis je le
répète la synergologie et une ce dossier
ans je m'en sert comme d'une piste de
réflexion
mais ça veut pas dire que ce soit ça et
que ce soit vrai et véritable à 100%
prendre ça avec des pincettes quand la
main droite couvre la main gauche
on est sur un raisonnement analytique et
on dit que les personnes sont sans
influence donc sous influence c'est à
dire que ce sont des profils de
personnes au moment où etienne leur
discours ça veut pas dire que c'est
comme ça dans toute la vie qui ne
prennent pas de décisions par eux mêmes
en gros qui ne prennent pas de décisions
sans consulter d'autres personnes et
pour régurgiter quelque chose donc si ça
s'est avéré si ce que je viens de dire
est avérée pour traduire la position des
mains alors ça veut dire que de tout ce
qu'il prend comme mesure de tout ce qui
nous amène il n'y a rien qui ne vient
directement de lui et c'est des choses
qu'on lui dit de faire qu'on lui
explique de faire que ce soit d'autres
politiques ou des scientifiques après on
a pas on connaît pas assez tout le
panorama
nous on peut parler que de l'instant et
cet instant veut a priori dire ça mais
en fait c'est normal qu'il ait pas voulu
reprendre sa position avec les gilet
jaune où il avait l'air d'un robot etc
parce que là on parle d'un truc de santé
donc il doit être absolument rassurant
au vrai auprès du grand public pour être
rassurant faut paraître sincère pour
paraître sincère il faut pas tout
contrôler et en même temps c'est pas
possible
aussi tout sera mis en oeuvre pour
protéger nos salariés et pour protéger
nos entreprises
quoi qu'il en coûte on serait pas sur
une forme d'hypnose conversationnel
voulu ou non voulues le quoi qu'il en
coûte ya là je crois qui correspond aux
quoi qu'il en coûte quand il parlait de
l'état pour prendre en charge les
malades pour sauver des vies quoi qu'il
en coûte
et on repasse à 14,19 pour protéger nos
entreprises
quoi qu'il en coûte on est sur le même
découpage ça plus on répète quelque
chose avec la même intonation là on n'a
pas tout à fait les mêmes gestes plus on
lancre dans la tête de quelqu'un donc il
a exactement le même prosodie et le même
découpage
la seule différence entre la première et
la deuxième fois c'est que la deuxième
fois il le dit un peu plus fort quoi
qu'il en coûte
quoi qu'il en coûte je serais pas
surpris qu'il le dise une troisième fois
avant la fin pour ancrer le truc de il
n'y a pas de petits sacrifices et on
doit tous le faire c'est bien pensé
l'ensemble des gouvernements européens
doit prendre les décisions de soutien de
l'activité
puis de relance quoi qu'il en coûte
j'avais en troisième quoi qu'il en coûte
je l'avais dit ou pas et il est plus
fort encore que le deuxième on a eu le
premier il a commencé auteur basse le
deuxième trois minutes après un peu plus
fort le troisième deux minutes après
donc on réduit le temps encore plus fort
quoi qu'il en coûte
quoi qu'il en coûte quoi qu'il en coûte
nous aurons sans doute des mesures à
prendre mais il faut les prendre pour
réduire les échanges entre les zones qui
sont touchées celles qui ne le sont pas
ce ne sont pas forcément les frontières
nationales
on a juste le jeune musulman sur cette
partie là du discours il a lâché un peu
alors aussi parce que ça fait quand même
20 minutes qui tient dans
l'interprétation c'est pas si simple
mais il ya un peu d'amusement comme
s'ils trouvaient cette pensée la
ridicule on a vu des roger léger sourire
hagarde il est là ça c'est des petits
sourires les ga [ __ ] je l' ai perdu
mon angle on le voit on doit passer en
vente au début c'est incroyable et ça
c'est de la vraie micro-expressions
parce que ça passe vite et à agir en
soit sur vous pour les jours les
semaines les mois à venir ok on a une
gêne que je compte sur vous un pâle de
temporalité pour les jours laissez ce
domaine il déglutit on à la gêne on voit
un petit peu la gêne des excuses le ddo
c'est pas de ma faute qu'elle va dire
des mois à venir
les mois à venir je pense du coup et
encore une fois c'est que mon avis
personnel à prendre avec des pincettes
mais moi quand je vois la ré juste avant
moi avec un du british membres les jours
les semaines et cette expression là sur
le visage un peu de peur on a les
ridules offrons à tous je pense que lui
projette plus du mois que de la semaine
encore une foi en l'avenir de l'irak
d'où djia si j'avais bon ou pas dans
cette analyse là mais
mais c'est mon sentiment à moi les
prochaines semaines et les prochains
mois
vous avez entendu les prochaines
semaines et les prochains mois on a
encore des soufflement il est la
déglutition dessus juste sur les
prochains mois écoutez les prochaines
semaines et les prochains mois
on a la même tête que de thaler et
écouter et en ahl des glissements
derrière je pense vraiment qu'ils
craquent que ça dure longtemps ou qui
sait que quoi qu'il arrive ça va durer
au moins deux mois mais à retrouver
cette force d'âme qui est la nôtre et
qui est pas si vous avez remarqué ou
c'est avoir marqué loïc mais autant les
deux premiers tiers de la vidéo était
très en balance avec les mains autant le
dernier tiers des recommandations et
très on avance on a vraiment ce geste là
qui revient à systématiquement ok
c'était une bonne analyse de 30 minutes
ça à mon cher loïc et meschers
gens qui regardent la vidéo comme
d'habitude les analyses non verbale que
je fais n'ont pas vocation à donner un
avis quelconque en fait juste on regarde
et on voit ce qu'on peut commenter c'est
ce qui a été fait j'espère que ça ça
vous aura plu vous avez été vraiment
centaines voire des milliers à nous
demander ça jeudi à nous parce qu'il y
en a contacté directement loïc a envoyé
des mails donc voilà c'est chose faite
la vidéo je ne sais pas quand est-ce que
vous la verrez pas ce qu'on va la montée
là tout de suite dans la foulée on va la
sortir dès qu'elle sera prête
je devais avoir une vidéo qui sort ce
lundi qui était une analyse de yann moix
versus eric zemmour sur un débat du coup
j'ai la décaler à mercredi
je pense pour laisser celle ci qui vient
qui vient comme ça s'est intercalé pour
conclure si vous n'étiez pas abonnés à
cette chaîne profitez-en pour vous
abonner pour l'icg et la vidéo avant de
quitter si vous avez regardé jusque là
ce que je pense que ça vous a plu donc
vous pouvez cliquer et la dernière chose
que je rajouterais parce que dans cette
période de troubles il ya quand même
autre chose qui existe le magazine
curieuse que j'ai lancé ce mois-ci que
vous avez reçue pour la plupart dans vos
boîtes aux lettres sinon il va il est où
que vous soyez dans le monde
il y avait une offre de lancement de 19
90 pour un an d'abonnement vous allez le
recevoir tous les mois qui était en
place avant le vrai prix de l'abonnement
qui sera de 29 90 par an cette offre là
elle s'arrête dimanche à minuit donc je
vous mets le lien dans la description
vous pourrez lire quelques pages de
d'une curieuse du numéro un qui est déjà
parti et vous pourrez vous abonner pour
le recevoir
durant un an à partir du numéro 2 et
sachez aussi que la première personne
qui s'y abonner
par respect de la tradition de la presse
on lui a offert un abonnement à vie
voilà je donnerais pas son nom c'était
une jeune femme mais elle est abonnée à
vie on lui rembourser la baule
l'abonnement et c'est un cadeau qu'on
fait aux premières personnes qui
s'abonnent voilà le lien en tout cas
vers curieuse dans la description vous
aurez toutes les infos sur le site les
questions vous avez par rapport à korian
vous envoyez un mail sur le mail qui
assure le site curieuse at curieuse
point fr merci beaucoup d'avoir regardé
cette vidéo à très bientôt
ciao